et bien priorité au direct regardez nous
motivons le convoi du président de tpm
père et lui à plus de 145 % des voix
c'est magnifique j'aperçois une main qui
s'agite une barbe bien taillée des
cheveux toujours un peu gras
malheureusement oui c'est bien lui c'est
le président c'est banal
extraordinaire il est évidemment
accompagné de la première dame danielle
macro quand la chaudière de l'elysée
comme nationaux mais à l'elysée
justement ils sont gros ils sont bien
entourés d'enfants alors est ce que ce
sont les leurs on ne sait pas on se bat
à l'otan et et l'abandon de la merkel et
du prochain en tout cas on attend
résonner l'hymne européen cette fois ce
n'est pas du giuly du miniou de prison
affiche clairement la couleur place à la
jeunesse quelle classe kate inité de la
part du président et sa femme danielle
macro celle qui évidemment est une place
extrêmement importante dans le coeur des
fans disent et c'est le caire toujours
fait tout pour se faire beau y avoir un
glouton en garde un mot quel record 1
ordination manilow le producteur de tpb
voilà c'est beau c'est grand c'est
historique ce qu'on est en train de
vivre ce qui passerait de 6 8
bavard président puisse contrôler par 8
à baron nous y label sera que j'avais le
bon niveau de mon record battu la vague
évidemment si c'est tout ce que dans qui
accompagne la venue du nouveau président
de bnp très belle réélection évidemment
je descends 45% des voix ces
conséquences historiques on est en 2022
et baba est à double dans 2 tb mpc
magnifique car il rend quelques classes
du cm1 porno
cette instance quand il dit la france y
la république
puis la merguez
[Applaudissements]
vous servir c'est normal ça
s'est gâté le
sentiment que ça va les enfants vous
êtes contente d'être avec brigitte
c'est vrai vous êtes content l'aimé bien
[Applaudissements]
micro micro sim à peine mais c'est fou
ces gens qui m'appellent annie monsieur
comment tu t'appelles mathieu jeannès
shine j'aime bien comment tu t'appelles
brigitte
est belle quand tu t'appelles je
m'appelle abel bonjour abel je n'ai rien
ça va jouer et bats
toi ça malgré six à treize
et vos prêtres et si j'adore commenté
coiffer merci tu es content de voir la
présidente
je vais faire un bisou
les enfants aventure
[Applaudissements]
ah
ouais
on était obligé on était obligé de faire
cet emprunt franchement on était obligé
de faire ça tombait un marché fait est
là la marche est bonne voire secret la
marque est la marche et colle vraiment
légal
les allées
j'avais de la jme met huit minutes
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je sais que ça va bien aller mais non tu
l'auras la paix même très grave et
transportent les ingrate excitant les
monnaies les manifs